la psoriasis es una enfermedad de la
piel que causa parches de piel gruesa y
enrojecida y produce comezón y escamas
plateadas
las dos capas Superiores de la piel se
llaman epidermis
y dermis
nuevas células en la parte inferior de
la epidermis se desplazan constantemente
hacia arriba y reemplazan las células
más antiguas que están por encima de
ellas normalmente las células tardan
aproximadamente un mes en realizar este
recorrido en la psoriasis las células
llegan a la superficie de la piel en
solo de 6 a 8 días debido a un problema
con su sistema inmunitario
los científicos piensan que su sistema
inmunitario confunde ciertas sustancias
naturales de su piel con Invasores
externos Esto hace que su sistema
inmunitario comienza un contraataque
llamado respuesta inflamatoria
la inflamación es una serie de cambios
que se producen en la piel que incluyen
vasos sanguíneos dilatados
crecimiento de más vasos sanguíneos más
células inmunitarias en la zona que
forman grupos
y la creación más rápida de nuevas
células de la piel
con el tiempo el proceso de inflamación
se convierte en un ciclo las células de
la piel dañadas envían una señal para
que más células inmunitarias lleguen a
la zona a su vez las células
inmunitarias hacen que las células de la
piel se multiplican rápidamente y la
piel se vuelva más gruesa esta ocasiona
zonas inflamadas en relieve con comezón
llamadas placas en la piel
los científicos piensan que la psoriasis
se transmiten las familias a través de
su ADN llamadas genes
usted puede desarrollar psoriasis si
tienes dos genes y luego experimenta
ciertos factores desencadenantes Como
por ejemplo lesiones en la piel piel
seca
infecciones
estrés tabaquismo
y ciertos medicamentos
Si tiene alguna pregunta sobre la
psoriasis hable con su proveedor de
atención médica